ก็สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋
ถ้าน้องอาร์ทตี้นักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนัก
เรียนทุกคนเอ่อโอเคครับผมน้อง Artist คะ
น้ำวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันนี้วันพฤหัส
ครับน้ออ้าวันนี้วันที่หาดวันขนาดนะคะวัน
ที่เท่าไหร่คะวันนี้วันที่ 18 หน้าวัน
พฤหัสบดีที่ 18 ครับวันนี้วันพฤหัสบดีวัน
ที่ 18 นะคะๆครับเดือนอะไรคะ 5 เดือนนี้
เดือน
พฤศจิกายนห่า
พฤศจิกายนนะคะๆครับปีพตเท่าไหร่คะปีพตต
2564 ครับ
[เพลง]
564  14 ก็ได้ครับปีคศเท่าไหร่ค่ะปีคศ
2010  21 ครับปีคศ 2000  21 นะคะๆครับ
หน้าตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะตอนนี้ใช่ไหมครับ
ตอนนี้นี้ตอนนี้เวลา
18:00 นมองหกโมงเช้าครับหกโมงเช้านะคะ
เช้า
R5 ทรายครับ 6:00 นเช้าครับ
วันนี้เนี่ยครู Arty มีอะไรมาให้ดูคะอ้า
วันนี้ฟัง 5555 ดูแล้วก็ฟังอะวันนี้เพลีย
ตี้มีมีอ่ามีอะไรคะพี่อะไรนะครับอะไรครับ
พี่แอ๊ดขอ
นะครับควรที่ลืมคนดิคิดถึงทุกครูเรียมใช่
ไหมคะ
โอเคที่มีแผนที่นี้น่ากลัวอะตี้นะคะมี
มีแผนที่วงมีอะไรบ้างคะในรูปภาพผ้าในรูป
มีอะไรบ้างนี่รูปมิตรงนี้นี่เป็นปั๊มน้ำ
มันครับก็ปั๊มน้ำมันครับคินดีเซลแก๊สโซ
ฮอลชายๆแล้วมีความมันนั่นเป็นเป็นลูกชิ้น
หนึ่งไหมอ่ะแฟนรูปที่ 1 เป็นปั๊มน้ำมัน
ครับ
อ่า Party เขียนแรกหนึ่งไว้ตรงนี้โอเค
ครับต่อไปรูปที่ 2 ครับรูปที่ 2 รูปไหนคะ
ของรูปอันนี้ครับหาขยายได้ไหมคะรูปที่ 2
นี้นี่รูปที่ 2 เป็นเป็นอะไรคะเป็นสถานี
ตำรวจครับ
ตำรวจตำรวจอยู่ที่สถานีตำรวจที่สถานี
ตำรวจมีต้นไม้ด้วยนะคะได้มีต้นไม้ 2 ต้น
นะต้นนะคะถ้ารักข้างหน้าสถานีตำรวจเป็น
บอดหรอคะใช่ครับเป็นบอร์ดหน้าบอร์ดบอกว่า
สถานีตำรวจมีตำรวจดิคนติ๊กเหตุการณ์อะไร
บ้างไว้เวลามีกระดาษใช่ไหมคะกระดา
ราป๊ะ 8 ช้าๆๆแปะที่บอร์ดหนีค่ะ
นะคะสถานีตำรวจนี้นะครับมีรูปที่ 3 ไหมคะ
ถ้ามีรูปที่ 3 ครับรูปที่ 3 รูปนี้เป็น
โรงเรียนผอ.โรงเรียนเป็นโรงเรียนโอเค
เดี๋ยวครัวติ๊กเขียนเลข 3 ไว้ตรงนี้ใช้
ครับเป็นโรงเรียนสวัสดีค่ะโรงเรียนมีกี่
ชั้นคะโรงเรียนหน้าโรงเรียนมี 2 ชั้นครับ
อ๋อมี 2 ชั้นชั้นที่ 1 ชั้นที่ 2 ชั้น 1
อยู่ข้างล่างค่ะล่างนะคะหัน 2 อยู่ข้างบน
ครับ 5 สายกะปิมีนาฬิกาด้วยนะคะอ้ามี
นาฬิกาอยู่ตรงนี้มีนาฬิกา
ถ้ามีนาฬิกาตายข้างหน้าตั้งนาฬิกาเป็น
อะไรคะอังหน้านาฬิกาเป็นประตูประตูเปิด
อ่ะเข้าไป
ในโรงเรียนค่ะแล้วข้างหน้าประตูเป็นสนาม
บอลเรื่องหาใช่ครับเป็นสนามกีฬา
หน้าเล่นบอลได้วิ่งก็ได้ก็ได้ทรายครับ
ขึ้นกีฬาที่สนามกีฬา
ใจเขาโค๊ดตี้ข้างหน้าโรงเรียนมีป้ายโรง
เรียนใช่ไหมคะอ่าใช่ครับเป็นป้ายชื่อป้าย
ชื่อโรงเรียนค่ะไปหาข้างหน้าโรงเรียนมี
ถนน
Sharp มีถนนถนนและที่ถนนมีสีเขาขาวอะไร
คะอ๋อตรงนี้เป็นทาง
หน้าม้าลายไปทางม้าลายใช่ครับ
5 มีสองทางม้าลาย 2 ทางได้ครับ
ที่โรงเรียนรู้เหมือนเป็นวันเวย์ใช่มั้ย
ใช่ครับโรงเรียนขับรถขับรถทางตามลูกศรนี้
ถ้าสอบได้ตามลูกศรถ่ายนะครับทางนี้ไม่ได้
ค่ะต้องขับๆนี้นี่ตามลูกศรค่าค่าย
ภาพที่ 3 ก็เป็นโรงเรียนนะคะภาย
มีภาพที่ 4 ไหมคะค่ะมีภาพที่ 4 ครับภาพ
นี้ครับภาพที่ 4  Ru หลายแบบนี้อ่า
กลัวตีขยายนี่อะไรค่ะครู Arty เป็นตึก
ครับที่ 20 เป็นตึกใช่ครับตึกนี้เป็นโรง
พยาบาลครับอ๋อโรงพยาบาลตายครับไม่สบายปวด
หัวนายครับปวดหัวไปโรงพยาบาลขวดอ้าปวด
ท้องก็ไปโรงพยาบาลท่านโอ๊ะปวดฟันไปโรง
พยาบาลปวดหูโอ๊ะ
พูดหูไปโรงพยาบาลครับอ่าโอเคนะครับกูอะ
ตี้ที่โรงพยาบาลมีรถใช่ไหมคะครูเอ๋ๆๆนี่
มีรถหน้าเรียกเรียกรถพยาบาล
r&d พูดรถฉุกเฉินไหมคะรถฉุกเฉินได้ครับ
บางทีอ่ะ
ดีจ้า
นะรถพยาบาลรถฉุกเฉินโอเค
มี The มีอะไรเอ่อดอกไม้ห้าใช่ครับมีดอก
ไม้อยู่หน้าโรงพยาบาลค่าโรงพยาบาลมีดอก
ไม้
[เพลง]
มีอะไรกูเอ๋อยากดูตรงนี้มีรถเหมือนกันตาย
ครับมีรถคันนี้เป็นรถขยะอ๋อ
รถขยะนี่มาเก็บเก็บขยะนายครับเคมีมี
ทิชชู่ใช่ไหมคะแล้วทิ้งไม่ใช้แล้วหานี่
ขยะขยะใช้ครับ a ไปติดแสงต่อนะ
อ้ามีรถจะอยากมีรถฉุกเฉิน
หนูรถพยาบาลอยู่ที่โรงพยาบาลตัวอยู่ที่
โรงพยาบาลนะคะ
r&f โรงพยาบาลอยู่ใกล้ๆจะผ่านหรือเปล่า
คะใช่ครับนี่มีสะพานสะพานอยู่ตรงนี้ใช้
ครับสะพานคิดว่าเราก็ใกล้ๆสวนใช่ไหมคะใช่
ครับมีสวนสวนมิสวนมีส่วนอีกยี่สุดสวนมี
ม้านั่งใช่ไหมคะใช่ครับมีม้านั่งนี่ 1 ตู
มาอยู่ตรงนี้นี่มานั่งน่ารักก็มีมีเสา
อะไรคะเสาแฟนเสาไฟนี่มีไฟล์ตอนกลางคืนบืช
กลางคืนมืดไม่มีพระอาทิตย์มีใฝ่ในครับใช่
ไหมคะขวดที่รอ 1 นาที
คือนี่กลัวนี่ก็ปิดมืดตอนนี้ก็ติ้งพืช
แล้วก็
เออ
กูอันที่ง่ายกว่าเนาะ
วิ่งปิดนะคะพี่วิ่งไงช่วยเห็นมืดหน่อยแค่
ปิดตรงนี้ก็ไม่รู้ใช่ไหมครับมืด
แล้วก็โอเคค่ะก็ถ้ามืดก็เปิดไฟใช่ครับ
เปิดไฟได้เปิดไฟก็สว่างค่ะว่าสว่างโอเค
ค่ะก็เมื่อกี้ภาพที่ 4 โรงพยาบาลหน่อยคะ
หน้าต่อไปอาทิตย์ที่ 5 ค่า p51 นี้ๆ
เดี๋ยวกลัวแต่เขียนเลข 5 ไว้ก่อนแน่ฮ่า
ฮ่าๆตรงนี้ครับถ้าเป็นอะไรคะ rg58 เป็น
สถานที่ก่อสร้างหอยังไม่รู้อะไรนะคะรู้
หน้าตอนนี้ก่อสร้างกำลังขุดดินให้รับไม่
ได้ผม
กำลังผมดินน้อยธนบุรินทร์น่ะหาทรายครับผม
ดินลงไปหาก็ซักห้ามเข้านะคะให้ครับห้าม
เข้าไปไม่ได้เข้าไม่ได้ใช่ค่ะ
อ๋อถ้างั้นมีภาพที่ 6 ไหมคะอ้าภาพที่โห่
Stick ควรที่มึงถามท่าที่ 5 มีรถอ่ารถ
อันนั้นเรียกรถอะไรคะรถมันขึ้นมั้ยใช่
ครับเป็นรถบรรทุก
บรรทุกดินนี่บรรทุกดินชายหาดนักก็เอาไหม
ผมๆครับผมลงไปนี้ดินอยู่ตรงนี้เยอะเลยใช่
ครับ
ถ้าต่อไปค่ะผ้าที่ 6 มีอะไรครับที่ 6 ภาพ
นี้คือ
ห้างครับโอเคชอบได้ๆที่ 5 แต่
5:00 นเราไปทำอะไรครับทำไมกูเอกชอบที่
ห้างครับตัว a ชอบซื้อขอซื้อนา
แหวนหมูออกไก่ขอ
เสื้ออาซื้อหลายอย่างเลยซื้อที่ห้างผู้
หญิงชอบห้างๆชอบห้างชอบซื้อด้วยชอบซื้อนะ
คะแต่ตอนนี้ไม่ไป
รออีกครั้งปีสองปีไปตอนนี้มีโควิชใช่ไป
ไม่ได้ไม่ได้ไว้ไปนะคะออกก็เป็นห้างนะคะ
ครับเป็นห้าง
มีอะไรมากๆที่เขียนเลข 6 ไว้ก็อ่าเห็น
เล็กข่มก่อนหน้า
ยังมีอีกครับมีพรุ่งนี้ก็อัพเดี๋ยวๆผม 6
ใช่ไหมอ่ะข้างบนจากเลข 555 ก่อสร้างกับ 6
อ่ะมีมีอะไรอ่ะกูอยากเขียนตรงนี้หรอครับ
ไปค่ะอ้าตรงนี้เป็น
สวนเหมือนกันใช่ครับเป็นตัวนี้มีแต่ส่วน
นี้มีดอกไม้ดอกไม้ได้ครับมีดอกไม้อ่ะที่
โรงพยาบาลมีดอกไม้อาอาที่ที่ส่วนนี้มีดอก
ไม้ 5 มากนะๆที่ห้างมีครูเอ๋ชอบลูกโป่งสี
แดง
ลูกโป่งรูป
ลูกใหญ่
ลอยอยู่บนบนของขา 5 และ GE  S  A  L  E  A
ชอบ
ราคา
ราคาราคาถูก
ผู้หญิงชอบเวลาเห็นลดราคา
นักเรียน
นักเรียนชอบรถราคาไหมครับ
คิดว่าชอบผู้ชายไม่ชอบ
สวัสดีชอบไหมอ่ะกลัวตี้ไม่ชอบเขาก็ให้เขา
ชอบรถราคา
นี่คะ
นะภาพที่ 7 ภาพที่ 7 ภาพที่ 7 เป็นอันนี้
ครับนี่
วงเวียนหรือเปล่าเวียนชายครับวง
อยู่ตรงกลางวงเวียนมีอะไรคะตรงกลางวง
เวียนมีน้ำพุน้ำหอมมีน้ำพุหน้ากายครับ 5
น้ำพุ
แล้วครั้งแรกใกล้ๆวงเวียนเป็นบ้านใช่ไหม
คะใช่ครับตรงนี้เป็นบ้านะมีบ้านมีบ้านนะ
คะพรุ่งนี้ก็มีบ้านแล้วตัว P คืออะไรคะ
ที่จอดรถ En ใช่ครับเป็นที่ที่จอดรถค่ะ
หายครับ 5 กู Arty คะสมนะสมมุติสมมุติครู
เอ๋ขับรถนะคะ
ขับรถแล้วครูเอ๋เนี่ยขับรถแล้วก็ไปที่โรง
เรียนวัดจากโรงเรียนไปที่โรงเรียนโอเคที่
โรงเรียนจากโรงเรียนครูเอกคลิป
เจ็บคอมันเจ็บคอเจ็บคอต้องไปโรงพยาบาลโรง
พยาบาลโอเคแต่ครูเอ๋โรงพยาบาลที่ไหน
โรงพยาบาล
ไปไหนอ่ะ
ควยตี้บอกครูเอ๋ได้ไหมคะถ้าไปโรงพยาบาล
ยังไงโอเคโรงพยาบาลหมายเลข 4 อ้านายครับ
กูอตตี้บอกเอ๋ทางไหนไปไหนไปทางไหนใช่ไหม
ครับเอ้ได้เลยกูเอกขับรถจากโรงเรียนจาก
โรงเรียนอ่ะโรงเรียนตีวาด
โอเครูปรถมีครับไปจากโรงเรียนทุกๆพระเอก
ข้างหน้าโรงเรียนออกจากโรงเรียนคู่ a
ต้องเร็วซะไปเลี้ยวขวาค่าออกจากโรงเรียน
ครูเอ๋เลี้ยวขวาครับเดี๋ยวขวานี่ฝา
ไปฮับแล้วก็แล้วก็ขับตรงไปตรงไปอ่าเลี้ยว
ซ้ายไม่ได้เลี้ยวขวาอีกใครขับเลี้ยวขวา
ๆๆฮ่าๆๆแล้วครูเอ๋เจอสามแยกเลี้ยวซ้าย
ครับเจอสามแยกมีตรงนี้เป็นสามแยกภู a
เลี้ยวซ้ายครับอ๋อถ้ากู a เลี้ยวซ้ายก็ไป
หาตำรวจมั้ยคะอ้าเดี๋ยวซ้ายไปสถานีตำรวจ
ในกูเองไม่ไม่ไม่ไม่หยุดไม่หยุดที่นี่อ้า
เอ๋นะคะออนไม่ตรงเข้าไปนะคะให้ตรงไปใช่
ครับจักท่านอย่างงั้นกูเองไม่ตรงไปอยู่
ข้างหน้าสถานีตำรวจตัวเองต้องเลี้ยวซ้าย
หรือเลี้ยวขวาคะเลี้ยวซ้ายหรือเลี้ยวขวา
อ่าอา
ขวดอี้คิดว่าอะคิดว่าครูเอ๋เลี้ยวซ้าย
ครับเลี้ยวซ้าย
อายเขาเที่ยวก่อนจะ
เลี้ยวซ้าย
ขายตรงไปเสร็จแล้วก็เลี้ยวซ้ายอีกอ้อ
เลี้ยวซ้ายอ้อเจออะไรคะเจอทางม้าลาย
ม้าลายออถ้ามีตำรวจเดินเดินๆก็ต้องหยุดรถ
หยุดใจครับให้คนเดินไปก่อนให้ตำรวจเดินไป
ก่อนใช่ครับอ่าเดินข้ามทางม้าลายครับแล้ว
ก็ก็ครูเอ๋ต้องขับรถตรงไปลองไปได้ครับลง
ไป
นะแล้วก็เลี้ยวขวาเลี้ยวขวาไปครับเลี้ยว
ขวาตรงไปสุดเลยไหมไม่ครับครูเอ๋มาเจอ 3
แยกตรงนี้อ้า
แย่ๆครับห้าสามแยกแล้วกูเอกก็เลี้ยวซ้าย
เลี้ยวซ้ายกูอัจจิน้ำมันหมด
ให้มีเบนซินไม่มีดีเซลแล้ว
น้ำมันหมดอ่ะเรา
อยู่ปั๊มพอดีนี่ปั๊มอ้าอยู่ที่ปั๊มน้ำมัน
เทอมน้ำมันได้ครับ
ก็ต้องเข้าปั๊มน้ำมันก่อนใช่ไหมๆครับเข้า
ปั๊มน้ำมันหน้าเติมน้ำมันมันก็เติมได้
ครับอ่าน้ำถังค่ะเต็มถังนะครับอ่ะเต็มถัง
เลยครับโอ้นี่
ห่า
เท่าไหร่คะอ่าเต็มถัง 1,000  200 บาทครับ
โอเค
กูแอ๊พติสต์เขียนได้ไหมคะ 1,000 บาท
1,000
200 บาทนะเต็มถังใจเงินมาจ่ายงาน
จ่ายเงิน 1,200 บาท
เสร็จแล้วครูเอกต้องขับรถออกจาก 5 ขับรถ
ออกจากปั๊มเลี้ยวซ้ายสายอ่ะเจ็บคอเจ็บคอ
มาที่สามแยกเจอสามแยกครับเลี้ยวขวา
อ้าวเท่ห์แล้วก็ขับรถค่าข้างสะพาน
ข้ามเหลือขึ้นคะฮ่าๆๆ
จะพาข้าตั้งค่าบนนี่คนไทยน่ะพูดสองอย่าง
ข้าวสะพานก็ได้สะพานได้
ก็ข้ามสะพาน
[เพลง]
แล้วก็ไปไหนต่อก็มาทั้งนี้สะพานลงสะพาน
น่ะก็ลงหาเลี้ยวซ้ายตรงนี้ถ้าครับแล้วก็
ตรงไปเลี้ยวขวาตรงนี้แล้วก็มาจอดรถตรงนี้
นี่เป็นที่จอดรถใช่ครับที่จอดรถนะคะ
จอดรถแล้วก็วิ่งไปหาคุณหมอได้อ่าวิ่งไปหา
คุณหมอนี่นี่เข้าทางประตู
5 ได้เขานะคะถ้า
เจ็บคอ
ไปหาคุณหมอที่โรงพยาบาลรายการที่ใน
ปาร์ตี้หากูเองนะไปหาคุณหมอเสร็จละหาย
หรือยังครับก็มี
ฉีดยาอ่อนฉีดยา
อีกอย่าด้วยอีกยาคุณหมอให้กินยา
อ้าวเงาะเสร็จแล้วครูเอ๋
อยากจะไปไปไหนครับไปไปไปไหนดีจะไปไหนดี
คู๋อยากจะไปช้อปปิ้ง
ตอนนี้ไม่เจ็บคอแล้วแต่แต่เจ็บคอไป
ช้อปปิ้งจ้าๆเย้ a ต้องขับรถออกจากโรง
พยาบาลอ่ะใช้ครับขับรถออกจากโรงพยาบาล
เดี๋ยวครัวตี้ลบก่อนลบฮางไปโรงพยาบาลก่อน
ตะเข้ค่าา The  Best ออกจากพยาบาลตรงไป
ใช่ไหมคะอ้าออกจากโรงพยาบาลครูเอกต้องลง
มาทางนี้เขา kuai ไม่ต้องข้ามสะพาน
ไม่ต้องไม่ต้องข้ามสะพาน of ไปใต้สะพานๆ
ครับอ้าขับตามรถขยะ
โอเค
ใช้ใช่ไหมคะใช่ครับเลี้ยวซ้ายข้ามคานทาง
ม้าลายอ่าผ่านทางม้าลายอะไรคะครู Arty
เจอ
วงเวียนอาหงส์เวียนมีเอาเวียนอาวงเวียน
น้ำพุ
ได้ครับเอ้อ
วงเวียนน้ำพุนะคะครูเอกก็ต้องขับวนใช่ไหม
คะขับวนใช่ครับเลี้ยวซ้ายหน้าขับวน R
ครับวนฤถ้าเบื่อปืนบื้นบื้นมาถึงตรงนี้
ถึงแยกนี้ค่ะไอ้คู๋เลี้ยวซ้ายอ่าๆครับ
เดี๋ยวซ้ายตรงไปเจออะไรคะเออทางม้าลายและ
เจอเจออะไรคะ 5 พรุ่งนี้เป็นสี่เเยกใช่
ครับอ่ากูเองต้องตรงไปหรือเลี้ยวขวา
เลี้ยวซ้าห้าห้าครูเอ๋จะไปห้างเหตุต้อง
เลี้ยว
สายท้ายอ้าใช่ครับเลี้ยวซ้าย
เลี้ยวซ้ายขับมาตรงนี้อ่ะกูเอกจะเห็น
ที่จอดรถอ่ะโอเคงี้ S  S  A  L  E
Cell อย่างเดียวอิอิถอดรถอยู่นี่ก็เอา
ตัว P อยู่ตรงนี้อ่ะตอนรถตรงนี้ค่ะตัวเอง
ก็ไปเอ้ยจอดรถในครับ
เชิญมา
เดิมเครื่องใช่ไหมดับได้ครับเรื่อง
เปิดประตูรถแม่ใช่ครับปิดประตูรถล็อครถ
แล้วก็ไป
ช้อปปิ้งอะไรครับไปซื้อซื้อเสื้อ 5 ซื้อ
จ่าย
ซื้อของกินใส่
ถ้วยกาแฟ
[เพลง]
ที่ 5 แว่นตา
ซื้อมั่วน้าได้ครับมีหมวกด้วยที่ห้างมี
หมวกร้านอาหาร
โกอาตี้งั้นรูปนี้ทั้งหมดมีอะไรบ้างคะวัน
นี้นักเรียนได้ดูได้ฟังอะไรบ้างคะอ๋ออ๋อ
วันนี้นักเรียนได้เดี๋ยวนะกลัวตี้ลบพวก
นี้ก่อนจะได้
หามองเห็น
ว่ามีอะไรบ้างวันนี้นะครับถ้า AR นะตึ่ง
เอกครับอ่าเริ่มจากที่หนึ่งนะครับที่ 1
เป็นกว่าตีขยายนะอะหยายจะได้เห็นชัดๆอ่ะ
ค่ะที่ 1 เป็นปั๊มน้ำมันครับปั้มน้ำมัน
ราคาภาพที่ 1 ใช้ครับภาพที่ 1 เป็นปั๊ม
น้ำมันค่าที่ 2 ค่ะภาพที่สองเป็นสถานี
ตำรวจครับสถานีตำรวจนะคะภายครับอาหมู่ที่
3 ขานี่ครับภาพที่ 3 เป็นโรงเรียนโรง
เรียนนะคะโรงเรียน
ใช่อะไรคะครับที่ 4 เป็นรองพยาบาลครับที่
4 เป็นโรงพยาบาลได้ภาพที่ 5 ค่ะ R ที่ 5
อ่อนี้เป็นสถานที่ก่อสร้าง
สถานที่ก่อสร้างนายคะเออครับที่ 6 ค่ะอ่า
นี่นี่พระที่ 6 ที่กูแอบชอบ
พี่ห้างครับๆนะคะนะค่ะข้างจะไปโรงพยาบาล
ก่อนนะ
ในโรงพยาบาลก่อนเพราะว่าเจ็บคอ 5
ค่ะครับที่ 7 นี่เป็นวงเวียนใช้ครับเทียน
นะครับวงเวียนนะครับแล้วก็มีแล้วก็มีอะไร
อีกครับมี
มิสวนสาธารณะที่สวนสาธารณะอ่าตรงอะไรคะ
ปาร์ตี้ใกล้ๆสวน 5 มีเก้าอี้
อ๋อก็หมายถึงสะพานใช่ไหมนิทาน
โอเค ammy สะพานเราขับรถข้ามสะพานขึ้น
สะพานที่อะไรที่สวนก็มีเก้าอี้ๆมีเก้าอี้
ครับแล้วก็มีโคมไฟที่สวนขายครับเมื่อกี้
ครู Arty กับกูอ่ะพูดกูอ่ะที่บอกมีเลี้ยว
ขวาเลี้ยวซ้ายกู Arty มีภาพเลี้ยวขวา
เลี้ยวซ้ายไหมคะอ้อมีครอบครัวที่มีภาพ
เลี้ยวขวาเลี้ยวซ้ายเดี๋ยวอ่าหัวติ๊บเปิด
ภาพ
เลี้ยวสายก่อนเลี้ยวซ้ายใช่ครับ 5 เลี้ยว
ซ้าย
เลี้ยวซ้ายเลี้ยวซ้ายเอ่อ
L ใช่ไหมครับอ้ะฮึท้ายเร็วซ้าย
เลี้ยวซ้ายอ่ามีเลี้ยวซ้ายอย่าซ้ายวงนะ
กลัวติ้งงงว่ามือชี้คนละทางกับลูกศรแล้ว
แกโอเคอ่าซ้าย
ครับโอเคแล้วก็มีเร็วซ้ายมีเลี้ยวเลี้ยว
ขวาใช่ครับอ่านี้เลี้ยวขวานะๆ
เดี๋ยวปากนะมีมีผ้าอาริย์เลี้ยวขวาอะไร
ครับอ่า
แล้วบนถนนมีอะไรอีกครับมิเอ้าข้างมาละนาย
ม้าลายใช่ครับทางม้าลายให้คนให้คนเดิน
เดินไม่ใช่เดินนะไม่ใช่ให้มาเดินไม่ใช่
ม้าลายคนเดินเชิญมาม้าลายม้าลาย
เหมาะสำหรับคนเดินเดินเดินข้ามถนนไรกับ
ข้ามถนนมีถนนมีถนนแล้วก็มีทางม้าลายนี่
ครับนี่นี่สัญลักษณ์คนเดินข้ามถนนข้ามทาง
ม้าลายค่ะ
มีอะไรโอทางกู Arty มีถนนมีมีสองมีมีเลน
ใช่ไหมคะได้ค่ะมินไป
กับมาไปข้างนี้มานี่ครับมีลูกศรอยู่อย่าง
นี้เดี๋ยวว่ากลัวตี้ขยายอ่านี่มีลูกศรค่ะ
อ่ะทางนี้ทางไหนที่ให้สุดก็คิดให้ฟังนี้
อันนี้ปลาใช่ไหมมาอ่าๆก็ไปปล่อยอ่าไปข้าง
หลังไปไกลๆทางโน้นอ่าแล้วมีเสาเสาที่มี
สัญลักษณ์ทางม้าลายข้างหลังสาวเนี่ยเรามี
อะไรคะอ๋ออ๋อโทษเรียกเกาะ 5 กรอบร้านขนม
หวานป้าปรางค์ใช่ครับอยู่กลางขนนถนนมีสอง
ฝั่งใช่มะได้ข้างเกาะกลางถนนเกาะกลางถนน
ชาย
ที่ไหนไม่รู้นะ
เหมือนกัน
มีมีอย่างอื่นไหมคะถ้ามีอย่างอื่นครับมี
อันนี้อันสุดท้ายอ่ะอย่างนี้ครับนี่ครับ
วงเวียนวงเวียนช้าวงเวียน
วงเวียนชาย
นะคะก็เป็นอาเราขับรถแล้วมีกลมๆเราก็
เรียกวงเวียนเปลี่ยนไปกับเราต้องขาวนไป
ปลงๆได้ทำวนเล็กเมากับวงเวียนอ่ะไป
เลี้ยวสหายเลี้ยวขวาขอไอโรงเรียนจะมีทาง
แยกออกไปมีทางแยกออกไปมีทางแยกออกไปใช่
อ่ะพี่กรุงเทพฯมีวงเวียนที่ครูเห็นมี 1  2
4  5
r-yes เยอะเห็นนะมี 5
ไปแท็กซี่
บางทีแท็กซี่ไม่รู้ทางไหนเห
รอออกทางไหน
นะอ้าไม่รู้ว่าจะออกทางไหนไม่ชอบวงเวียน
นะ
ฮะ
โอเคค่ะโอเควันนี้เราเรียนเรื่องอะเลี้ยว
ซ้ายเลี้ยวขวาหน้านะครับเดี๋ยวคราวหน้า
คราวหน้าเบอร์โทรกลับมาเรียนกันต่อนะเวลา
หมดแล้วใช่ไหมคะใช่ครับเวลาวันนี้เวลาหมด
แล้วหมดแล้วครูอตีนต้องไปออฟฟิศแล้วใช่
ไหมอ่ะเอ่อใช่ครับตอนนี้ถึงเวลาไปทำงาน
แล้วไปโอเคค่ะให้ค่ะขอบคุณนะคะครู Arty
ของนักเรียนนะคะคุณทัพพี่เอ๋ครับขอบคุณ
ค่ะหนูสวัสดีครับทุกคนครับพี่ค่ะใครบ้าง
ในนายพบกันใหม่คลิปหน้าค่าใช้ครับอ่า